[Music]
you the only person i ever met
belonged in this guy
just remember you belong down here with
us too okay
[Music]
the commanding officer calls you one of
the best pilots he's ever seen
it must be hard being a naval aviator
absolutely
[Music]
the whole world's looking different do
you ever think that you'd be in a
squadron with a colored aviator
lieutenant tom hudner jesse brown it's
good to meet you
we're taking a slight detour on the way
home say again
what are you going to find out about
your wingman cruising at 10 000 feet
lieutenant
put him in a little bit of trouble who
knows you might get a peek at who he
really is
north koreans came pouring over the 38th
our parallel need help
and we're up
we know this day might come and it
doesn't make it any easier
the most important thing is this
we bring everyone
home
mistakes get us killed
i can't tell you how many times people
have told me to give up quickly
die even
if i did i wouldn't be here
what do you want me to do just be my
wing man
the real battle in all of life
someone that people can count on
show off that was pretty good that's
good
[Music]
foreign